will you first stop here fresh yeah so
fresh I'm not gonna be this fresh after
for Nikki Glaser
I never feel fresh on my first one I
always feel like just I'm too tired I
hate it you look wide awake I know I've
been off I got up early it's raining I
had to run in the rain a little bit burn
me up that hard but enough to wake you
up
I like your I haven't read the whole
book but it's actually really great it's
all photos of Garry Shandling and a
little late I liked it it's an easy
thing to peruse you can pick it up in
the middle and look at it there's a
picturing I'm obsessed with it saw a
picture not a meal channeling Letterman
Leno and Carson what a great picture I
know and then while they existed and
also gary has a completely different
attitude than them like they're kind of
so in their showbiz moment he's just
kind of staring off like in his own
space it's it's a really cool I wish I
knew him Sarah Silverman introduced me
to him once going to the cellar and I
guess the only time I ever met him I
wish I would have known was he when you
met him he was fine he said hello and he
was you know what do you mean what do
you mean when you say that how was it
how was he but that was always a thing
of Gary is like you just there were many
different versions of Gary sometimes
Gary's really like shut down and and you
know he might not be like super warm
Gary like he wouldn't be mean but just
might be in his own head in a way where
people were like what just happened you
know and other times he would just be
super sweet and talk to you for a really
long time
I guess cuz she introduced me it was
like a from mutual friend it wasn't
maybe it was less awkward but he seemed
if he was friendly I think I just went
in went on but he was always a guy I
remember his first I want to say it was
one of his first tonight should have
been Joan Rivers was guest-hosting and I
taped it off my TV out of a cassette
recorder Alyssa hood for years I loved
him he was the best guest host out of
all of them yeah and he didn't he didn't
take it cuz of his show is that the
reason cuz he wanted to do he was
hosting him in Leno were alternating
filling in for
when Johnny would go on vacation and he
was also doing its Garry Shandling show
and then he just said like I'm too tired
I can't I can't do it and and he had
this thing where he wanted to be amazing
in a way that I don't think I've ever
heard anybody talk like he was like I'm
not gonna do this 9:00 show unless I'm
just crushing it and if I'm tired I
won't so that I'm just not gonna do it I
wish you rich had that you know Sandra
said everyone does he was a genius but
also driving everybody crazy because his
bar was so high and if he didn't
couldn't get to his bar really miserable
and and angry sometimes comics are weird
too it's like we set a bar that's high
and yet in a way we know we're not gonna
achieve it but there's something
comfortable and fairly miserable
sometimes for us remember back after he
started guest hosting did he still come
on and do stand-up spots yeah yeah yeah
he still went on and Annie was always
crazy funny and would prepare for it
like he was hosting the Oscars it was
just a level of care that there are
people who do it like that buddy I mean
it was obsessive I mean that was the
joke with him and said he would have
pads with tons of papers and literally
when he's walking out on The Tonight
Show you see him like putting the papers
like into his pockets he's writing for
the second he he walks his family gave
you access to all this stuff right the
pictures the the notes was there any
stuff where they were like I would
rather you don't see that well I mean it
was 30 years of journals so he said
there's certainly you know
sections where you were like well I
guess probably this doesn't go in the
book did you read stuff that he wouldn't
have wanted you to read I probably
wouldn't wanted me to read a lot of it I
guess I mean I think you know he was
talking about making a documentary about
the journals himself so I knew he wanted
to do it but you know
then just like a couple of no girlfriend
issues or weddings like that it wasn't
you know for 30 years it wasn't much
that was embarrassing
at all I mean shockingly so were you
nervous going into it like if I had to
read one of my closest friends personal
writings have they gone oh yours one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM a/v